انها الثمينه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصهاب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
قائد مشاه البحريه الامريكيه يكشف نقاط
ضعف بلاده ويقول نفتقر القدره لردع الصين
بحريا
امريكي جديد على خلفيه اعتقال موسكو
للصحفي الامريكي بتهمه التجسس
البيت الابيض يقول ان روسيا تقايض كوريا
الشماليه الغذاء مقابل السلاح
اردوغان يحذر من ان شائعات حدوث زلزال
باسطنبول تخيف السكان وتدفعها للنزوح من
المدينه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في اخبار الساعه
نبداها من فرنسا حيث تشهد العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس في هذه اللحظات صدمت بين
الشرطه والمحتجين الرافدين لرفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى اربعه وستين عاما
من هناك معنى مراسلنا فادي الدهوك فادي
الصوره من عندك تبدو مشتعله
نعم صهيب هذه الليله مشتعله بشكل كبير
هناك تصعيد كبير بدا قبل ساعات من الان
المتظاهرون الذين خرجوا في تظاهره لرفض سن
التقاعد رفع سن التقاعد وايضا للتنديد
بعنف الشرطه انتشروا في الشوارع وبداوا
باشعال الحرائق كما ترون الان وقوه
الاطفاء تحاول جاهده ان تسيطر على هذه
الحرائق طبعا هذه الحرائق حتى الان لم تطل
الممتلكات وانما هي موجودات كانت في
الشوارع يحاول المتظاهرون ان يقومون
باشعالها على كل مسار التظاهر حيث يسيرون
ايضا الشرطه تقوم بملاحقتهم وتحاول
السيطره عليهم هناك عادات كبيره من
المتظاهرين التي الذين تفرقوا في شوارع
مختلفه وهذا ما سبب صعوبه لقوات الشرطه
بالسيطره عليهم كما ترون هذه الحواجز التي
رماها المتظاهرون في الشارع هي لاعاقه
قوات الشرطه من اللحاق بهم يشعلون النيران
ايضا وهذا ايضا سبب لمنع الشرطه من الوصول
اليهم هذه التظاهرات كما ذكرت هي ضد عنف
الشرطه بعد الصور العنيفه التي نشرت على
وسائل اعلام فرنسيه وتسريبات ايضا
لمكالمات حول هذه المساله كان هناك اصابات
مناعه الشرطه قوات او منعه الشرطه اجهزه
الاسعاف من الوصول الى المتظاهرين فتفجر
هذا الغضب والان هناك نقمه شديده على
الشرطه وحتى ادانات وانتقادات كبيره لوزير
الداخليه جيرالدرمانه نعم طيب بالنسبه
للمتظاهرين هل يمكن القول انه المظاهرات
لهذا اليوم قد انتهت فادي ام انها ستتجدد
غدا ايضا
التظاهرات لا يمكن معرفه اوقاتها لانها
بدات تخرج بتنظيم الطلاب والشباب وهؤلاء
يقومون بتنسيق تظاهراتهم بشكل منفرد
ومستقل عن النقابات هم يقومون بالدعوه الى
هذه التظاهرات بشكل فجائي على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي يحددون اماكن مختلفه
ويخرجون في هذه الشوارع لذلك من هناك
صعوبه شديده حتى من قبل السلطات لمعرفه
هذه التظاهرات اين تخرج وكيف ستخرج كما
ترون هنا ايضا عدد من السكان يحاولون
اطفاء هذه الحرائق التي التي اشعلها
المتظاهرون هؤلاء ايضا سكان من هذه
البنايه يحاولون مساعده قوات الاطفاء هناك
تعزيزات طلبت من قوات الاطفاء لمحاوله
السيطره على الحرائق هناك حرائق في معظم
الشوارع هذه الليله والشرطه تحاول اللحاق
بالمتظاهرين لكن الصعوبه هي ان المتظاهرين
يقومون بوضع حواجز في كل الطرق التي
يسيرون بها لمنع الشرطه من الوصول اليهم
صهيب نعم ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
الصوره الحيه مباشره من باريس فريدهوك
[موسيقى]
في خضم الصراع صراع النفوذ المتزايد بين
الصين والولايات المتحده ادلى قائد مشاه
البحريه في الجيش الامريكي بتصريح مثير
رجح فيه كفه الجيش الصيني على نظيره
الامريكي في حال نشوب اي حرب في المحيط
الهادئ اعتبر ديفيد برجر في التصريحات
التي ادلى بها لمجله نيوزويك ان قوات
بلاده تفتقر الى القدره على رضع اي صراع
مع الصين في المحيط الهادئ هذا واشاد قائد
مشات البحريه الامريكيه بالصين معتبرا
اياها المنافسه الوحيد القادر على الجمع
بين القوه الاقتصاديه والدبلوماسيه
والتكنولوجيه لتحدي النظام الدولي وبحسب
قائد مشاه البحريه الامريكيه فان الصين
باتت تتفوق بشكل واضح في صناعه السفن
والتي قامت باستعراضها مؤخرا خلال
المناورات العسكريه حول تايوان كما ان
الصين تبدو اكثر استعدادا لاي مواجهه
عسكريه بحريه من خلال اجراء عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ من السفن اكثر من اي دوله اخرى
خارج مناطق الحرب الفعليه هذا واقر
المسؤول الامريكي بان هناك انخفاضا في
توافر السفن والمنصات البحريه في ظل
التركيز بشكل اكبر على اسلحه الجويه
والبريه وفضلا عن تراجع صناعه السفن نسبيا
في امريكا قياسا بالصين فان شرائها ايضا
عرفت توقفا مؤقتا
[موسيقى]
قالت كارينا جون المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض ان اتهامات التجسس لمراسل صحيفه
وستريد جورنال في روسيا سخيفه مشيره الى
ان روسيا تحتجز الامريكيين بشكل منهجي من
اجل الضغط على واشنطن
اتهامات التجسس هذه سخيفه استهداف الحكومه
الروسيه للمواطنين الامريكيين امر غير
مقبول ندين احتجاز السيد قرش باشد
العبارات لا توجد مؤشرات على استهداف
الصحفيين في روسيا كما تعلمون هذا امر
حزين وشائع ان تحتجز روسيا الامريكيين
ولهذا كنا واضحين بشان ضروره عدم سفر
الامريكيين لروسيا انها غير امنه
اذا من مسار الى اخر سرعنا ما يتطور
التصعيد الامريكي الروسي على خلفيه الحرب
الاوكرانيه اخرها تصعد معركه الجواسيس
الموضوع هنا يتعلق باعتقال موسكو لمراسل
صحيفه
هذا ما اعلن عنه جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي الذي كشف ان جيشكوفيتش جمع معلومات
تشكل سرا من اسرار الدوله حول انشطه احدى
المؤسسات العسكريه الروسيه وذلك تنفيذا
لتعليمات امريكيه وفقا للاتهام الروسي
اتهامات لم تتاخر الصحيفه الامريكيه في
نفيها جمله وتفصيلا داعيه الى الافراج
الفوري عن مراسلها ومعلنه في الوقت نفسه
تضمنها معه ومع عائلته حرب التصريحات
تواصلت على خلفيه هذا الاعتقال حيث ردت
المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه بالقول ان الكثير من الاجانب
يستغلون وضعهم كمراسلين للتغطيه على انشطه
غير صحفيه وهو الحال بالنسبه لمراسل
صحفي امريكي روسي الاصلي يتقن اللغه
الروسيه يبلغ من العمر 31 عاما ووالداهم
قيمان في الولايات المتحده منذ 1979
مراسل يغطي روسيا واوكرانيا لدى صحيفه
وولد جورنال الامريكيه كان مراسلا لوكاله
موسكو قبل 2022
عمل كصحفيا في صحيفه موسكو تايمز الصادره
بالانجليزيه في 2017 اول مراسل لوسيله
اعلام امريكيه يعتقل بتهمه التجسس في
روسيا منذ الحرب البارده اعتقل في مدينه
كاترينبورغ بجبالاورال متورط في جمع
معلومات سريه بحسب وكاله الاستخبارات
الروسيه قررت محكمه روسيه حجزه لمده شهرين
على ذمه التحقيق بتهمه التجسس
وفي جديد هذه القضيه قررت المحكمه في
موسكو حتى مراسل الصحيفه الامريكيه
احتياطيا لمده شهرين مع امكانيه تمديد
حبسه في نهايه هذه المده اتى الحكم بعد
جلسه محاكمه مغلقه اعلنت فيها المحكمه
ايضا عن تصنيف الملف كقضيه سريه للغايه من
جهته تشبث المراسل الامريكي ببراءته مؤكدا
انه غير مذنب في اتهامات التجسس المواجهه
اليه هذا ولم يسمح لمحامي الصحفي المتهم
بدخول قاعه المحكمه والاطلاع على
الاتهامات المواجهه لموكله على حد قوله
فيما دعى البيت الابيض المواطنين
الامريكيين الى مغادره روسيا فورا
وفي جديد الحرب في اوكرانيا لا تزال معركه
باخمت متواصله حيث ان مصيرها لم يحسن بعد
في ظل زحف الروسي المتواصل مقابل دفاع
اوكراني مستميت في اخر التطورات اعلن
الرئيس منطقه دونيتك الموالي لروسيا ان
التطويق المدينه الاستراتيجيه بالكامل بات
قريبا جدا
فماذا تبقى للقوات الروسيه لمحاصره بخموت
بالكامل بعد تسعه اشهر مشاهدينا من القتال
نجحت القوات الروسيه بقياده مجموعه فاجنر
في محاصره المدينه من ثلاث جهات وهي
الشمال الجنوب والشرق وتبقى الجهه الغربيه
الوحيده الصامده لحد الان في وجه القوات
الروسيه والتي تحاول السيطره عليها لتطويق
المدينه بشكل كامل ويحتدم القتال بشكل
اساسي في المنطقه الشماليه والتي تعرف او
تعرف كثافه متزايده لهجمات القوات الروسيه
الباحثه عن زياده الضغط على المنطقه
الغربيه من الشمال هذا وتمكنت القوات
الروسيه من تعقيد عمليه وصول الامدادات
الى الجيش الاوكراني عن طريق قصف الج سر
الذي يربط المدينه في بلده شازوفير غربا
ورغم الاعتماد على قوه باجنر الى ان روسيا
استعانت ايضا بقوه جيشها المنتشره في
المنطقه الجنوبيه القريبه من قريه غروبلوك
[موسيقى]
هكذا متحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان على الاطراف المدنيه والعسكريه
ستواصل الحوار اليوم وغدا حول بعض
التفاصيل قبل التوقيع على الاتفاق بسبب
الخلافات حول دمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش الا ان مصادر مطلعه كشفت للعربيه عن
اجتماعات مرتقبه لاحتواء تلك الخلافات حول
اليه والجدول الزمني لدمج قوات الدعم
السريع في صفوف القوات المسلحه
معنى من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا اخر المعطيات
حول هذه المشاورات لتدليل هذه الخلافات
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش السوداني
مرحبا صهيب بكل المشاهدين بكل تاكيد ما
زالت الخلافات موجوده حتى الان وتباين في
الاراء والمواقف حتى اللحظه صهيب لم
نستطيع ان نتحصل على تاكيد قاطع
للتوقيع يوم السبت ولا النفي القاطع ليوم
السبت لان الامر ما زال معقدا ومتعلقا
بامور كثيره ابرزها موضوع دمج قوات الدعم
السريع بكل تاكيد هذه المعضله التي هي
مركبه بكل تاكيد ايضا لانها تحمل في
طياتها الكثير اولا قوات الدعم السريع
تقول انه لابد من اصلاح المنظومه الامنيه
والعسكريه بشكل عام واصلاح الجيش نفسه حتى
يتم الدمج الجيش السوداني يتحدث عن دمج
خلال سنتين وطرق قوات الدعم السريعه ان
هذه فتره قصيره جدا الان هناك ليان فنيه
يجب ان تبدا في صياغه التوصيات النهائيه
لورشه الاصلاح الامني والع سكري لالحاقها
بالاتفاق النهائي الذي يفترض ان يوقع يوم
السبت الاول من الشهر المقبل يظهر ان هذه
اللجان ما زالت لم تنتهي من توصياتها حتى
الان لهذا التباين
طيبون الشاسع ما بين الطرفين
في عجاله سالمه هل هناك اي وساطات لانهاء
هذا الخلاف
الان هناك اجتماع لكل القوه الموقعه
الاتفاق الايطالي بشقيها العسكري والمدني
في القصر الجمهوري لم يصدر عنه اي بيان
حتى اللحظه لم تقدم فيه يعني اي اشارات
لكن القوه الموقعه لاتفاق الايطالي
والناطق الرسمي باسم العمليه السياسيه
خالد عمر يوسف اكد انه لم يتم حتى الان
تاجيل هذا التوقيع وهذا ما يفهم منه انه
التوقيع باقن بحسب حديث شيخ لكن الوقائع
تقول
الوقائع تكون لا اعلان بالفشل ولا اعلان
بالنجاح سنتابع ما ترشح عنه هذه المشاورات
سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
لمساعدتها في منع حظر التطبيق من الولايات
المتحده تيك توك تستعين بمدراء امريكيين
بينهم مستشار سابق لاوباما
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد قال مصدر صحفي في
اسرائيل ان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي الذي
ادت اقالته من قبل رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو الى تفاقم الازمه الدستوريه في
البلاد هذا الاسبوع قد يحتفظ بمنصبه وصرح
مقربون من الوزير انه لم يتلقى اي خطاب
اقاله رسمي من نتنياهو وقال مصدران مطلعان
على الوضع ان زعيم حزب شاص درعي يعمل على
ابقاء جلنط في منصبه
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان شركه تيك توك لا ترغب في
الاستسلام في وجه خطر الحظر المتصاعد
للتطبيق في العديد من البلدان الغربيه ومن
اجل خوض هذه المعركه استنجدت الشركه
الصينيه بثلاث شخصيات سياسيه واقتصاديه
بارزه قامت بتعيينها لتقديم المشوره لها
ويطمح التطبيق الصيني الشهير الى اقناع
السلطات الامريكيه بعدم صلته بالحكومه
الصينيه ونقلا عن صحيفه وسط الجرنون فان
الشركه عينت كلا من ديفيد بلوف وجيم
ميسينا وهما من ابرز الساهرين على حملات
باراك اوباما السابقه اضافه لزينيا مورشا
رئيسه الاتصالات السابقه في شركه
ونقرا عن الصحيفه دائما فان الاشخاص
الثلاثه ساعدوا الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تيك
توك لاكثر من شهر قبل جلسه الاستماع
المثيره للجدل في مجلس النواب الامريكي
الاسبوع الماضي
معنى من واشنطن البحث في الشونه الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس استاذ ايهاب
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه هل تنجح تيك
توك في التغلب على مساعي حظرها بشكل تام
في الولايات المتحده والغرب عموما من خلال
تعيين هؤلاء المستشارين هذه الشخصيات
الامريكيه
نعم اهلا بحضرتك وبكل المشاهدين طالما لم
يكن هناك اي انواع من انواع الاتهامات
بالتجسس مثبته على الاوراق
واستخدام بيانات المواطنين الامريكيين او
الاعضاء في تيك توك والذين لديهم حسابات
هناك والتي تقدر باكثر من 150 مليون دولار
سيظل هذا السجال قائما بين الطرفين بين
شركه الصينيه المملوءه الملكه لتيك توك
والحكومه الامريكيه من خلال طبعا المشرعين
الامريكيين واجهزه الدوله المختلفه لذلك
حتى اللحظه بالرغم ان تيك توك هناك
محاولات حتى من الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب لمنعه ووقفه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مرورا بهذه السنوات الاثنتين في
فتره الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن الا انه لم
تستطع كل الجهات الداخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تمنع التطبيق من العمل لانه
لم يخالف حتى اللحظه اي من القوانين
المتعلقه
يعني تبادل والم علومات الخاصه
باصحاب الحسابات او انتهاك لاي حظر او لاي
طبعا بيانات متعلقه بالحكومه الامريكيه
نعم عذرا على المقاطعه سنذهب لمتابعه هذا
التقرير حول ذات الموضوع ونعود اليك
الاستكمال النقاش اذا مشاهدينا حيث وبعد
هذه الضغوط التي تعرضت لها شركه باي دانس
المالكه لتيك توك بادرت هذه الاخيره
بتطوير تطبيق جديد اطلقته في الولايات
المتحده
وصفات طبخ غريبه ومواد تجميل اضافه الى
نصائح الموضه هذا المحتوى الذي يقدمه
تطبيق لمن ايت الوافد الجديد على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الذي اطلقته شركه باي
دانس المالكه لتطبيق تيك توك في امريكا
مؤخرا بعد اطلاقه في اليابان عام 2020
وقد تم تنزيله سته عشر مليون مره الى الان
الاعلان عن هذا التطبيق في امريكا تزامنا
مع الضغوط الكبيره التي تعرضت لها شركه
تيك توك في الدول الغربيه فقد تم استجواب
مديرها التنفيذي شاوزي تشو امام الكونجرس
بخصوص مخاوف حول امن وخصوصيه المعلومات
حيث تشك واشنطن ومعها عواصم غربيه اخرى في
ان بكين تستطيع الوصول لمعلومات مستخدمي
تيك توك في امريكا والغرب وقد تستعملها في
جمع معلومات استخباراتيه تطبيق لمن ايت
الذي وصل الى المركز التاسع بين العشره
الاوائل في متجر التطبيقات الامريكي قد
يكون حسب مراقبين مناوره قامت بها بعد
دانس للبقاء في السوق الامريكي في حال
صدور قرار بمنع تيك توك بشكل نهائي انس
نماسي العربيه
استاذ ايهاب هل هذه هي الخطه لبايد دانس
الملكه لتيك توك للبقاء موجوده في السوق
الامريكيه
يعني بكل تاكيد هي فرصه جيده لشركه بايت
دانس كي يكون لديها ايضا سلاحا اخر اذا
جاز تعبير استخدام هذا اللفظ
تكنولوجي موجود داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يستطيع من خلاله المواطنين
الامريكيون تنزيله والتعامل معه كما يتم
التعامل مع تيك توك ولكن الفكره في شيء
الفكره ان المساله ليست اليوم منع تيك توك
فقط يعني اذا ما صدر اصدر المشرعون في
نهايه المطاف قانونا بمنع تيك توك فهذا
سيعني منع شركه وبالتالي اي تبعيه لهذه
الشركه تعمل داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في اطار تقديم الخدمات
التكنولوجيه المحوسبه في هذا الاطار سيتم
منعها وبالتالي سيتم منع اليمن ايت هو
الاخر بالتبعيه يعني سندرج وينسحب هذا
القانون عليه يعني كما هو على تيك توك
ايضا ايهاب عباس الباحث الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
خوفا من ان ينقلب السحر على الساحر يقود
الى الماسك حمله تطالب بوقف تطوير برنامج
لانه يشكل خطرا كبيرا على المجتمع دعوه
ماسك هذه جاءت عبر رساله مفتوحه وقع عليها
اكثر من الف شخص دعوا فيها الى التوقف
لمده سته اشهر عن تطوير انظمه اقوى من
روبوت الدردشه
الذي اطلقته شركه
الرساله طرحت عده اسئله ابرزها هل ينبغي
ان نطور عقولا غير بشريه قد تتفوق علينا
عددا وذكاء وتتفوق علينا وتحل محلنا وهل
يجب ان نسمح للالات باغراق قنواتنا
الاعلاميه بالدعايه والكذب وتقول الرساله
الموجهه لتشات انه لا يجب تفويض قرارات
كهذه لقاده تكنولوجيا غير منتخبين والتاكد
من ان اثارها ستكون ايجابيه وان مخاطرها
ستكون تحت السيطره
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه وكاله الامن
والسلامه ومواجهه الطوارئ توفر اكثر من
500 كادر امني لخدمه المعتمرين في رمضان
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد حذر خبراء الارصاد
الجويه من ان سلسله من العواصف مصحوبه
باعاصير قاتله من المتوقع ان تضرب اجزاء
من الغرب الاوسط والجنوب في امريكا خلال
الاسبوعين المقبلين وخاصه الجمعه وهو
اليوم الذي وصفه الخبراء الخبراء بيوم
الجمعه المميت باعتباره احد اسوا الايام
التي ستمر على البلاد وقالت هيئه الارصاد
الجويه الامريكيه ان 16.8 مليون شخص
يعيشون في المنطقه الاكثر عرضه للخطر فيما
يجب على اكثر من 66 مليون شخص ان يكونوا
في حاله تاهب يوم الجمعه
ونبقى في امريكا حيث قال نائب المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه هناك
خلال مؤتمر صحفي ان على الصين الا تاخذ
توقف رئيس التايوان في الولايات المتحده
كفرصه للمبالغه في رد الفعل
رسالتنا للصين لا يزال مفادها انه لا يوجد
سبب لتحويل توقف رئيسه تايوان في الولايات
المتحده الى شيء ليس كذلك او استخدامه
كفرصه للمبالغه في رد الفعل
[موسيقى]
حضر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من
الحديث المتكرر عن زلزال مدمر محتمل في
اسطنبول وقال اردوغان ان هذه الانباء تثير
هلع المواطنين ما جعل البعض يترك المدينه
ويذهب الى ولايات اخرى ربما تكون اكثر
امانا
[موسيقى]
الى فقره من الحرمين الان حرصت وكاله شؤون
الامن والسلامه ومواجهه الطوارئ والمخاطر
بالرئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
والمسجد النبوي على توفير اكثر من 500
كادر امني لخدمه ضيوف الرحمن فيما تواصل
وزاره الصحه السعوديه جهودها لتقديم
خدمتها الصحيه والعلاجيه المتميزه لضيوف
الرحمن وقاصدي البيت الحرام ويعد مستشفى
اجياد للطوارئ بمكه المكرمه المجاور للحرم
المكي الشريف من ابرز مرافق الصحه التي
خصصتها السلطه السعوديه لتوفير الرعايه
الصحيه والطبيه العلاجيه لهم يقدم
المستشفى خدماته للمرضى والمراجعين على
مدار اليوم
معنا من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي مراسل
العربيه سلطان اهلا بك معنا ما الذي تمكنت
من رصده من مظاهر تسهيل
يعني دخول وخروج المعتمرين وكذلك ارائهم
حول الخدمات المقدمه في هذا الموسم
الرمضاني
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه نريد ناخذكم اليوم في زاويه
مختلفه لنريكم هذه العربات الكهربائيه
التي عملت عليها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
وخصصتها للمعتمرين في عمليات الطواف او
حتى في السعي خمسه الاف عربه كهربائيه
ومتحركه موجوده هنا في الحرم المكي يستطيع
المعتمر والمعتمر الاستفاده منها عبر
التطبيقات وحجزها في وقت مسبق واستلامها
في احد الادوار الثلاثه نشاهد اكثر من 95
الف مستفيد من هذه العربات الكهربائيه منذ
بدء شهر رمضان وحتى اليوم هنالك عدد كبير
من المراقبين والمشرفين الذين يعملون على
مراقبه السير ووضع التنظيمات وتخصيص
المسارات بشكل كبير جدا لذلك نشاهد عمليه
الترتيبات الكبيره ايضا نقدر ناخذها يعني
نقوم بالتجربه معكم سويا هي عباره عن عربه
كهربائيه هنالك سرعات مختلفه لها تعمل
البطاريات الكهربائيه او الشحن الكهربائي
هذه العربه يستطيع استقلالها اكثر من
ثلاثه اشخاص لاداء مناسك العمره لنتحدث
على خمس ساعات تشغيليه يستطيع المعتمر او
المعتمر الاستفاده منها اكثر المستفيدين
من هذه الخدمه هما كبار السن وذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه وكذلك من يعانون من
امراض مزمنه او امراض في القدمين لذلك
نشاهد هذه العربات يتم استقلالها من قبلهم
والاستفاده منهم في الميزانه في الادوار
المختلفه في الحرم المكي في كل من
الميزانين الاول والثاني يستطيع من خلالها
الذهاب المعتمر حجها عبر التطبيق او حتى
حزيها بشكل مباشر وهي باسعار رمزي باسعار
لايجار رمزيه لا تتجاوز 115 ريال للعمره
الواحده ايضا هنالك فتيات سعوديات يقومون
بمرافقه كبار السن لمساعدتهم والتسهيل
عليهم في حال عدم استطاعتهم للقياده نعم
طيب فقط مسارات هذه العربات يا سلطان يعني
هي فقط للتنقل ام يمكن استخدامها ايضا في
الطواف ربما في الطبقات العلويه حول
الكعبه المشرفه يا سلطان بالفعل فس نعم
نعم في السعي والطواف في الادوار نتحدث عن
الدور الاول
الاسطحيه مخصصه كذلك في عمليه التواصل
السعي كل الادوار متاحه للاستخدام
ممتاز نعم طيب وهل رصدت اقبالا عليها نحن
نتابع الان على المباشر يعني اعداد كبيره
من المعتمرين يستقلون هذه العربات الجديده
هذه العربات الكهربائيه
لحد الان كذلك ما الذي رصته كذلك من اقبال
المعتمرين عليها سلطان
ما يقارب المليون و200 الف شخص يدخل الى
الحرم المكي بين معتمر ومصلي هذا رقم واحد
سلطان
سلطان عذرا الارسال تقطع قليلا ربما بسبب
حركه العرب الكهربائيه ولكن هي بالفعل
يعني زاويه جديده وتطور لافت الحقيقه
وطبعا من ضمن الخدمات الجديده التي توفرها
السلطه السعوديه لضيوف الرحمن في هذا
الموسم الرمضاني شكرا جزيلا لك من الحرم
المكي الشريف اذا سلطان السلمي شكرا زياد
دعت وزاره الصحه العمانيه المواطنين الى
عدم السفر الى تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه
الا للضروره القصوى
بسبب تفشي فيروس ماربورج في البلدين وقالت
وزاره الصحه العمانيه انها تراقب تفشي
المرض في البلدين كونه شديد العدوى وتصل
نسبه الوفيات به من 60% الى 80%
[موسيقى]
وصلت الحكومه الصينيه اعمالقه التكنولوجيا
في البلاد الى ارضيه للتفاهم حول وضع حد
لنزيف الخسائر في القطع فابيكين بدات
بالفعل تغيير تعاملها مع عمالقه
التكنولوجيا في البلاد والكلام منقول هنا
على شبكه سي ام بي سي الامريكيه السبب
وراء الموقف الجديد هو خساره الشركات
التكنولوجيه الصينيه لاكثر من تريليون
دولار بسبب تدشين حمله تنظيميه صارمه لقطع
التكنولوجيا اواخر العام 2020
الشركات الصينيه ساهمت بدورها في تغيير
موقف الحكومه الصينيه من خلال اتخاذ
اجراءات تلائم التوجه الحكومي ومن بين
ابرز النماذج على هذا التقارب هو الخطوات
التي اتخذتها شركه علي بابا للتجاره
الالكترونيه والتي اعلنت عن خطه لاعاده
الهيكله فالشركه كشفت انها ستنقسم الى ست
وحدات بهدف تعزيز قدراتها التنافسيه وذلك
في اكبر عمليه اعاده هيكله في تاريخها منذ
24 عاما
خطوه علي بابا هذه استجابه الى حد كبير
لرؤيه الحكومه الصينيه التي تعارض تكتل
الشركات التكنولوجيه العملاقه هذا ولم
تتاخر الشركه في جني ارباح المخطط الجديد
حيث عادت اسهمها الى الارتفاع في بورصتي
[موسيقى]
افادت صحيفه
يحقق في شراء ترامب صمت امراه ثانيه كان
على علاقه معها في عام 2006 واوضحت صحيفه
ان علاقه ترامب مع عارضه الازياء السابقه
دامت لعشره اشهر اضافت ان ترامب دفع لشراء
صمت عارضه الازياء في نوفمبر عام 2016 اي
خلال فتره حملته الانتخابيه للرئاسه في
المقابل نفا ترامب وجود تلك العلاقه
ختام اخبار الساعه تذكيرهم بابرز العناوين
قائد مشاه البحريه الامريكيه يكشف نقاط
ضعف بلاده ويقول نفتقر القدره لردع الصين
بحريا
توتر الروسي الامريكي جديد على خلفيه
اعتقال موسكو لصحفي امريكي بتهمه التجسس
البيت الابيض يقول ان روسيا تقايض كوريا
الشماليه الغذاء مقابل السلاح
اردوغان يحذر من ان شائعات حدوث زلزال
باسطنبول تخيف السكان وتدفعهم للنزوح من
المدينه
شكرا على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]